hey everyone this is Alessandra and I'm
here to talk about metal wolf chaos XD
the remaster for From Software's cult
hit from the original Xbox
before the days of the stoic Dark Souls
from software was a niche developer
nestled between releases of the mecha
action series ARMA core and the
occasional oddball side project 15 years
ago they released a game that blended
these two talents together in the form
of metal wolf chaos in the years since
it has lived something of a second life
as an internet meme so it's been
especially strange to see it return for
a third with a remaster so with that I
want to take a quick look back on the
history of metal wolf chaos and talk
about why it's so bizarre and somewhat
eerie to see it back to the White House
putting you in the role the 47th
President of the United States Michael
Wilson you battled legions of soldiers
and machines of war across America
following a coup led by Vice President
Richard hawk
essentially metal wolf chaos is this
weird pastiche of American action films
and Japanese mecha anime playing through
this strange satire of American culture
today can be a fun trip down memory lane
circa 2004 developed on a budget and in
under a year by 30 developers metal wolf
chaos keeps things simple leaning
heavily on the over-the-top mecha action
with this revolving set of weaponry it's
a setup that seemed like it would have
made for a decent action game for the
North American audience however it would
never arrive in the West the original
metal wolf chaos for the Xbox was a
japan-only release positioned as a game
intended to attract new players to the
system unfortunately it wouldn't make
much of a dent in the market and its
release came and went at the time
publishers were already transitioning to
the upcoming Xbox 360 and the games
satire of terrorism and American culture
likely made it a tough sell playing
through the game now it's hard not to
draw parallels with the events and
storytelling tropes of the game with
today's political climate with homegrown
terrorism fascism and propaganda on the
rise in the u.s. it can make some of the
events of the game feel eerie even when
its story is totally absurd metal wolf
chaos is a political game even when it
focuses on dumb fun action its original
release came during the height of Bush
era jingoism and the bizarre story and
characters reflect that to play a metal
wolf chaos is to contend with a barrage
of one-liners melodrama and cheesy
platitudes of what it means to be an
American and it does everything with the
utmost sincerity it's essentially a
Japanese anime honed through an American
fetishize lens crafted by Michael Bay
though the u.s. missed out on the full
game some Western players have the
chance to try a small slice of the game
thanks to demo discs from the official
Xbox Magazine one in particular featured
a hidden demo for metal wolf chaos
allowing players to jump into the game's
early levels set in San Francisco unless
you own an imported Japanese Xbox or
modified your system to play games
region-free this will be the only way
for Western players to experience the
game but in 2016
indie publisher devolver digital whose
past works include hotline Miami and The
Shadow Warrior reboot reach
after fromsoftware on twitter offering
to get the game released in the West
after the tweet went viral devolver
digital and from software began their
collaboration or to remaster for modern
consoles when compared to the original
metal wolf chaos xt keeps things
faithful low poly count in all some
notable changes however include the
upgraded resolution to play at 4k and a
new safe system that feels a bit more up
at the times in a way though the low
budget offers an aesthetic that adds
charm to the ridiculous plot and
straightforward gameplay in that regard
it fills that similar so bizarre it's
good space that games like deadly
permission inhabited
metal wolf chaos never lets up with its
headfirst approach to satirizing
American action films and culture in
many ways the tone and plot of this cult
hit lands harder now than ever before
likely more than the creator's ever
imagined
[Music]
you